aaron apke welcome to simulation
alan thank you for having me man
thanks glad to be with you
so good
yeah
so pumped for our convo bro
me too i was i was looking through your
youtube channel and i was like oh he's
had a bunch of my friends on this will
be fun
and same thing with you same thing with
you having so many conversations with my
friends
so we're like overlapping the same
networks
um
the background in the course of miracles
and law of one
finding the
parsing all of the planets repositories
for truth wherever we can find it in the
mystic traditions and retreats
um
[Music]
yeah and
now being able to
share with other people sort of like an
accelerated
with our other selves the accelerated
path the direct path that doesn't get
too lost doesn't go through too much of
the noise
um
yeah that's what i've that's what i've
noticed about our like some similarities
it's pretty cool yeah why waste time
right
yeah
actually i think this is a great i think
this is a great place to start actually
if you were to give like your distilled
um version
of what you found out to be like the
nature of reality
yeah like what would how would you
describe
it
the nature of reality huh
yeah it's like there's less you can say
about it really
it becomes so much more epic as your
awareness expands that there's less and
less i think it's more difficult to
describe it um
but this is what's so interesting for me
to talk about is that
we you had mentioned wanting to talk a
little bit about the idea that gaining
tons of spiritual knowledge can actually
take you farther from reality sometimes
and fatten the spiritual ego more
and i think we've all experienced that
for sure and it's
possibly even a
necessary and inevitable part of the
awakening path but
at a certain point you learn that your
concepts can't actually bring you to
reality
right that
the the things you know and learn don't
actually touch reality that it has to be
experienced and lived and embodied and
that calls for a very zen approach
of the sort of like the wu way approach
of uh non-action like i'm gonna stop
predicting analyzing thinking i know
living from conceptuality
i'm gonna just start living from
spontaneity just being with what is
without trying to know it or understand
it with the mind just accept what is
surrender to what is and let it
do whatever it wants to do in me and i
just trust that that supreme power
that is moving all of life is just doing
its work like the medicine
is going to work in me
and uh it's it almost seems like a cheat
code right because you're like actually
i do less and less and evolve more and
more as i go along
so that's what's been uh really exciting
for me to talk about lately
nice
cool
so
there's a couple threads there we can
pull on um one of them is like just how
simple it is when referring people to
like the nature of reality to just
recognize that this is consciousness
talking to itself
yeah
and then it's like oh like that like
that that makes sense like that's i can
see how that's unity i can see how
that's
um and then
and then like
uh another good one is that like you'll
when when will you come to the end of
exploring an unbounded
map
you know you'll never come to the end
like that's what infinity is you'll
never come to the end of
of of exploration of expansion of
possibilities of potential and so um
then that one and and then um
like playing on what you said i love
that point and i think this is another
great topic um for us to touch on is uh
i think this probably happened for both
of us where we picked up a lot of
concepts and a lot of knowledge and um
and there was a
a conceptual intellectual mind that was
quite active and it was
um
and it's it's interesting because as
soon as
i relax that and i'm sure same case for
you like the relaxation of that is
exactly what opened up a deeper state of
emptiness of self-interest
and yeah there was
yes and then the the buddhist anata that
no self ended up becoming more and more
apparent in experience and then the the
capitalist self this roaring s god self
is all that is left in terms of seeing
itself everywhere in every one in
everything and so the what is-ness like
you described in terms of just allowing
this the devotionalness
to
it
like you said it's a medicine like life
is medicine
that's so good yeah actually play on
play on that a little bit more and like
what you've seen um with the people that
you're serving and them like waking up
to that process of like letting go of
the conceptual and just letting that um
life as medicine oneness sort of do
itself
yeah yeah
well that's an important part of of
teaching anyone i think in this space is
that you you must always turn them back
to themselves turn them back to their
life and understand
as much as these teachings may be
helpful or feel expansive ultimately
they won't apply in you or flourish in
you until you take them to reality and
live them out and
try them out right in your life
experience
and i think that's what devotion means
to me
is that
when we realize that the supreme guru is
life
and that's
the only thing i need to devote myself
to
then you just start paying really close
attention right
and there's um
something shifts inside of you that
there's just like when you're in love
with anything to be in love with
something really is to be devoted to it
so when you when you see reality as it
is and you would just ask you know how
would i define reality
one of the ways i think
i experience reality
is
i don't know how to
put it into words i might say something
like
like aching beauty
oh yeah that almost just annihilates you
right it's you start tuning into it
all the time in that
when you're chasing knowledge in the
beginning of the journey perhaps
there's a desire to have these
transcendent experiences
you know there's a desire for the
mystical moment the mountaintop
mind-expanding mind-altering
experience and then there's nothing
wrong with those those are great and
very helpful for sure
but then we get addicted and to them and
chase them and we overlook the
ordinariness
which is also infused with reality and
with brahman and expansion
and because the mind is looking
to reality as being a mountaintop
experience it sort of says yeah like
that that altered state
that i achieve and the oneness the unity
cosmic consciousness that's reality and
then i come back down to normal life and
it's not reality
you know it's less valid or something
like that
and you start to see through that subtle
judgment
that layer of judgment in the mind that
you just had overlooked for so long and
you go wow i've been classifying reality
in categories and it doesn't have
categories
they're you know just
just to sit here and sip my tea
in the morning
is
you know
a perfect expression of all that is
and so we stop overlooking those things
and find that they're also infused with
beauty almost to the point where
you're you're experiencing
that beauty in everything you do
that sometimes i feel like i almost have
to shut it out a bit so i can function
normally
like you could be maybe in a you know a
conversation with someone and like you
just become overwhelmed with the essence
of the creator the expression of the
creator that's like beaming off of them
and you can start to get blissed out and
and you're sort of like man i gotta like
i gotta come back to this conversation
because i'm not even paying attention to
what they're saying you know it can be
like that it's almost it can be
overwhelming and
and you want to be overwhelmed by it but
you also want to be able to be in the
world all the time and be present with
what is so it takes integration right
there's a
there's a balance that has to be struck
within you of um stabilizing in that
state and i think that's um probably why
a lot of
um beings and and realized masters who
when they're going through their
awakening they go to isolation for a
long time because maybe they want to let
that process play out without all the
the distractions and then at a certain
point they feel stabilized in it and
they can come back out into the world
and teach
and i think a bit of that plays out in
our lives for those of us who maybe
can't go
hide in a cave for 10 years and meditate
life is teaching us always how to
integrate a non-dual awareness
with living in the world of duality and
paying my bills writing my emails having
conversations right all the ordinariness
you find it's it's just as divine
there's there really is no distinction
between duality and non-duality
non-duality isn't better or more valid
it's like they both are an expression of
the one and so i think that's devotion
right is realizing that and seeing that
life is my greatest teacher and so
whatever life is doing is what i want to
be doing
so good
i love that
so
there's two things there that i think
are great
um
i think it was da vinci yeah life being
the greatest teacher nature being the
greatest teacher
and also just
in general
like is that not obvious that
like that life itself is like a
processing system that life is
infinity just processing
and actualizing potentiality like it's
just it's really it's really becomes
evident and then it's um
you called it like a an aching beauty um
because there is it's like the
polarities the duality non-duality are
the same um or the simultaneity of them
um is really important so
you have like uh another way to say that
is maybe like a graceful fire of sorts
like uh like
this this is this is a for sure uh
a fire like all of the
yes
everything that's happening with like
with with awakening but also even at
like a a cellular level with like the
manufacturing of proteins and all this
type of stuff it's a fire it's movement
it's impermanence um but it's so
graceful in the sense of like it's so
beautiful it's like you said you can get
warped
um just your awareness can be so
saturated with love and light that
you're just like
drooling at the love that is present and
it's just so
like oh it's just it's
nourishing right that level um of love
and
and um when when you sort of see
that um as the like the mountaintop and
where you were are one thing and then
right so then there's like the anchoring
then or like the integration of said um
realization and awakening into the just
classical everyday life and in service
that's really you know the
one of one of the big things that we
communicate is the integration of the of
awakening into daily life and into
especially into service and to serving
the collective
yeah integrated awakening is what it's
all about because
i think when we talk you know you
mentioned how non-duality and duality
are one and the same and there's no real
distinction you know
i think we need to
really let that sink in and what the
implications of that mean
yeah because
it's so easy for the ego to grab onto a
shiny
non-duality concept and use it to really
bypass the world of duality
which is why i love the law of one as
i'm sure you do because raw makes sure
to make that point where it's like look
yes
self-realization requires you to accept
that you are the creator and be that and
step into that knowledge but also
rest in the balanced awareness of being
a soul on an evolutionary journey that
has some distortions to be seen and
worked out
both are at the same time true
and i see in in non-duality circles a
lot it's it's very it's a very tempting
um escape route for the ego to say oh
i've learned i've seen the ultimate
reality and it's nothingness arising out
of nowhere happening for nobody so
there's no one to look inside anymore
there's no one to inquire there's nobody
here
and so when triggers happen they're like
no no no no one to look inside no one
nothing to devote to there's just
nothing
and it's you know it's sound it's true
from the ultimate sense right that's
that is the highest possible teaching
but if we're if we're trying to grab on
to that too early it just becomes
another weapon for the spiritual ego
to delay our realization with because
we've we have this concept that we think
is the ultimate reality and i always
want to say
you know that's technically true there's
nobody to look inside in all of that but
i know that's not your lived experience
because you wouldn't be talking about it
like this if it was
right it's the ego it's professing how
enlightened it is through you
and so for you it's like no you can know
that that's true yep there's no one to
look inside and say well if there's no
one to look inside why do you keep
telling me to do it it's like you know
maybe don't worry about that so much
just keep looking inside right keep
finding the division within yourself and
becoming aware of it bringing it back to
truth
and when
when your awareness is ready for that
realization that the true non-dual
realization of there is no person
there's no one looking inside there's
just looking is happening but no one's
doing it right when you're actually
ready for that to drop in and be
embodied it will just happen to you
right it'll just occur to you you'll see
it in your lived experience it'll it'll
connect somewhere and in a deeper place
of awareness and there'll be such a
peace and a grounding from it of like oh
almost like a joke was played on me and
now i see it
there isn't a doer of actions there's no
one healing itself you know that's just
going on
as as the creators having this dream of
itself but i am that
so i always like to encourage people not
to be in a rush
um to claim those high level concepts
because i think this is why ancient
masters
for for thousands of years in the
buddhist tradition and hindu traditions
have
kept those teachings
for very very very advanced disciples
and they don't give those things to
newcomers right as often because they
know it's
it's so tempting for spiritual ego to
grab that kind of a truth and use it and
weaponize it
and so they they really just want to
teach their newer disciples service to
others right
devote yourself to a higher to the
higher truth and just the the basics of
awakening and once that has been
integrated to a certain extent then
there's actually the bandwidth in you i
think
to understand nonduality in a way that
doesn't
fatten up the spiritual ego
perfect
yeah and this plays directly into true
simultaneity as well like if you can
hold all of it at once as well like
if you like distilling down the nature
into the most
uh simple and um direct pointing
possible is
amazing and like that's what should be
the target and not something that's long
convoluted unneeded and so when you do
visit things like simultaneity of being
able to both be
a seeming individual
that has a soul that has lessons that
etc on behalf of the one and yet also at
the same time having a duality where
there was a veil of forgetting and i did
forget that i was the one and now i
apparently woke up through this veilless
veil and now am the one and non-duality
which was i was the one the entire time
and there are no individuals and there's
only the one for getting and remembering
itself and i think and i think that
that's a really good way to put it is a
true simultaneity of all of those things
and if you can put that into like the
first when somebody says what's my
nature when they seek is to provide them
with that simultaneity off the bat then
they also don't go into the fattening of
the spiritual ego and all of the rabbit
holes of that distract them for years um
yeah yeah
yeah i mean in a sense the fattening of
the ego will serve them as well
you know like like we said in the
beginning this probably happens to
virtually everyone on the awakening path
at some point and there's a lot you
learned from that
but but it's interesting how much we can
expedite the journey those
those processes of the journey by you
know having good little pointers and and
signposts hey just watch out for this
you know just watch out for the way ego
loves to grab onto these shiny concepts
and start parroting them around and i
even see a lot of non-duality keyboard
warriors out there you know who are like
disagreeing with everyone's post about
everything no no you're all wrong so
you're you're infusing ego into this
there's no person and they just get on
there man and they're just ripping
through people's instagram posts
and i'm like see
i don't think the buddha would be on
instagram you know rebuttaling everyone
for their nonduality
yeah it's so good yes yes
there's almost the hilarity of
the
simplicity that it was but that was
being overlooked and so that's another
reason why
buddha and so many others just rumored
to just be like there's more
enlightenment present in this flower
than there is in the spiritual text
and
just yeah
like
so and that plays into what we were
saying about falling in love with just
the sip of tea and falling in love with
the breath itself and falling in love
with seeing the one in the eyes of the
apparent other and just doing that
so much um to where
you
just channel
love you emanate love you are love and
um
and then and then it life becomes much
easier too because
you
you don't suffer
you don't cause suffering you shine love
everywhere
you serve life that way um
and like what else could what else do
you want like there's nothing else
except that
you're so nailing it man i find that to
be more and more true as time goes
forward
that that love is always the most
cutting edge thing to me
doesn't it seem that way like people can
get stuck in concepts about emptiness
and you know the the ultimate state is
the void his voidness and just being
lost in this emptiness no mind you know
perfect silence
and that is an aspect of the natural
state absolutely but if there's no love
there
it's like it's sort of dry and tasteless
it's not that interesting but even in
you know what's happening in the world
right now or an interpersonal conflict
you have with someone and to when you're
able to bring love into that rather than
just
i think sometimes we can
especially when we get good at
becoming pure awareness and just being
the witness of life just being the
observer we can almost put life at a
distance because you're like i'm just a
witness nothing's happening
it's like that's true in one sense from
the absolute sense but there's also the
relative which says that a lot is
happening a lot of evolution is
happening a lot of catalyst is happening
and life wants you to meet that
but it requires love to meet it you have
to love reality otherwise there will be
a part of you that can use emptiness as
another sneaky way to kind of put life
at an arm's distance because you're just
sort of dismissing everything is it's
just the arising of mind it's nothing
right
and i find that love is more cutting
edge than that
isn't it it's just more radical it's it
takes more gumption i think to go there
to meet life with an open heart and
that's that's the beauty we're talking
about when we say like the sip of tea
can just overwhelm you with bliss
because because you do experience
ultimate reality in it you experience
the divine in something so seemingly
ordinary that it blows you away that the
divine is so all-pervading and
everything you're like man there's
nowhere i can look but i don't see
ultimate reality expressing itself yes
that to me is bliss that's joy
yes oh
yeah there it is
yes
oh so good and i love i love how you
said that with love being the cutting
edge
that
in order for you to meet
the school that life is for itself
that
to come with the love for the school for
itself like
showing up with love for school
otherwise the catalysts come and like
you said there's not
a showing up with love for the catalyst
that i generated for myself
versus showing up with love every moment
is like oh if i just reached too fast to
grab my water and knocked it over that
is just a reflection of how fast i was
moving that i wasn't that i wasn't
moving with love and with gentleness and
sensitivity
um and there's mindfulness yes
yes so there's so many like examples um
like this and love is also present when
yeah like when we interact with each
other is
like right now seeing love talking to
itself when we said earlier
consciousness talking to itself when we
say the one talking to itself the one is
awareness love and light so this is love
talking to itself
and to really feel that is to feel no
separation
um yeah and that's and then when all of
those last bits of separation dissolve
the only thing that's left is just that
love and that light and and you um
and service because then then um
and i'm sure this actually comes up
quite a bit i i feel like i feel like we
have so much to talk about and one of
the things that i think might be most
interesting for us and also for our
audiences
is the most common patterns we talked
about the spiritual ego grasping
concepts and getting over inflated and
that type of thing um
we we
are so many good things that we could
talk about like how to find the most
signal the fastest is another good one
to talk about but i would um i would
also like to talk about how
um what shows up most common in terms of
uh like lack beliefs in terms of people
feeling uh unworthy or separate or
like they want validation from the
outside world and then how do you help
them like see like to transmute that
um
so let's do that and then i'll also want
to talk about like uh creativity as well
as another thing desire
nice
yeah can you repeat that question one
more time
so what are the most common lack beliefs
that are showing up and how do you help
um
[Music]
the people you serve transform that
yeah i think one of the most pervasive
lack beliefs is exactly what we've been
saying here which is
the belief that
any any aspect every any moment of life
is
lacking total enlightenment you know in
any way
we do that to ourselves all the time
some moments are holier than others some
moments are more spiritual than others
and that's a huge lack belief that has
to be corrected if we are to see
supreme guru teaching speaking through
everything
so good bro yeah keep going that i would
i would for sure start with that one
um you know in my master class i one of
the things i cover is i go into um what
i call the three beliefs of ego
which
sort of speak to the three
negative emotions that we suffer from
which i would classify as sadness or
really just lack
belief that i'm incomplete
sadness anger and fear
and that there's three kind of core
beliefs that
the ego is only ever pulling from one of
these three beliefs to create the
thoughts that take us away take us away
from truth
and the first belief is the belief in
lack
if you had to verbalize it it would be
like i am incomplete
i'm not enough something is just missing
inherently right yeah yeah and so that
that belief creates the foundation for
the second belief
which is basically that my happiness or
my fulfillment depends on outcomes
yes
things outside of me will fulfill me
right external fulfillment is the second
belief
and that belief causes anger
because any time we're trying to get
fulfillment from the world and we get
blocked
blocked from our fulfillment or our
attachments that creates anger in the
system
anger is like the energy the
the emotional body creates to blast
through that wall that's blocking me
right use more force to get through it
and get the outcome i want
so that's the second belief and then the
third one is also um follow suit from
the second one which is i am the doer
i'm i'm in control
so we have i'm incomplete my happiness
depends on outcomes and i am the doer of
actions which is a funny sort of paradox
or contradiction
i love how a course in miracles actually
says the ego is a contradiction
because we know the ego believes it's
lacking
but at the same time it also believes
i'm the all doer
i'm the doer of everything i'm the
controller the initiator of experience
i'm doing all of it
but like both can't be true right you
can't be lacking and incomplete and
unworthy and inadequate and be the doer
of everything
so they contradict one another but ego
just doesn't let us notice that right
that our beliefs about who we are are
totally contradictory
so that belief in lack has to be
corrected first because it's kind of
sets the foundation for the other two
that follow and if you can correct the
belief in lack and you knew that there
was absolutely nothing lacking
which is a very deep conviction i think
that has
almost endless depth to it
then you would not believe that there's
anything outside of you that can fulfill
you
that would be seen as an absolute
illusion
and you would also not be able to
believe that you're the independent doer
of actions because absolute total
abundance also implies there's no lack
of action being done there's no lack of
motion activity all of it is abundantly
provided already by reality so i'm just
witnessing it i'm just enjoying it i'm
just experiencing it it's all happening
of its own accord that to me is the
state of like absolute abundance right
there's nothing i can claim credit for
because i'm just absolutely overflowing
with that sense of inner fulfillment
and that's the state of the uh tata
right is one who is not divided at all
within
uh it's it's a state of just
non-division non-separation
and so really it's to me solving the
belief in lack is
that daily journey of looking inside and
saying where am i divided in myself
what division still exists within me and
how can i bring that division back to
love back to unity
beautiful
hmm so good i love the first point on
the transformation of lack belief um
because then if from
from source if the first and this is
what buddha taught with dependent
origination if the first thing that's
coming from
emptiness from void from sourcefulness
is
a
belief in lack
then that's going to create separation
fear anxiety
wanting to extract happiness
from material objects relationships
i just i love that because it goes right
at the heart of
of of it which is if you if you know
what nature is from source
then you know there's never any lack and
you know that
like i am absolute sat [ __ ] on the
existence consciousness split
man does everything just flow from that
so so to shift oneself from um lack
believing lack is possible uh is first
and foremost that's
yeah that's so so good because it's at
the source it's at the root um
yeah and then the fruits shift because
the fruits change based on the root
nourishment if the root nourishment is
deprived which it is it's deprived if
you believe in lack
right then yeah then the fruits are
going to be they're not going to be
fruits
and that's why then there's like sadness
depression anxiety but if the roots are
nourished because
um true knowledge is
is
present in the entity then
it's
so clear that the fruits that emanate
are service to others the fruits that
emanate are wholeness it's wholeness
i love that i love the going directly to
absolutely nothing is lacking that's so
direct
yeah but as you know like the emotions
we feel are just the effects
of our thinking our belief system so by
the time i feel sadness or anger or fear
something's already gone astray in my
mind
and so i just you know
simply teach to start back engineering
that emotion sit with the emotion feel
it and be like hey what message are you
trying to tell me
and i find
whenever there's sadness
hopelessness
weariness depression of any kind and you
really
sit with that emotion and inquire into
it express yourself to me it will always
say i'm lacking something
that's where the sadness originates so
then
once you know that that's actually the
cause of sadness is the belief in lack
then you just have to question lack
itself does lack apply
to reality does it exist in reality
and of course you find that it doesn't
exist except for as a figment you can
never point to lack right you can't show
lack demonstrate lack prove it put it on
a scale
you can't do that
so sitting with that awareness over and
over through inquiry just allows it to
become a deeper conviction
and the conviction naturally
um flourishes within you as that feeling
of peace or as bliss
yeah and um i like how you pointed to
metacognition that's one of probably the
most um important entry points um for
um for people is when you when you feel
um sadness or suffering is to just gain
a level of
an increase in awareness or an increase
in perspective or to just use your
breath to just slow down
and to see like what is this negative
emotion trying to teach me um and it's
and it's usually that i'm believing in
lack right now or um
or that
um
because you don't the the interesting
thing is you don't ever feel that when
you're serving people when it's an
unbelievable freedom
that's felt when when you're in pure
service when you're the directional
arrow is so directed toward the other
self's heart and just focus on them that
there's so much freedom and
felt there
yeah that's when you 100 no lacks not
possible yeah
yeah
it's it goes back to what christ said
about when you when you serve when you
give don't let your left hand know what
your right hand's doing i mean don't let
your ego take credit for the service
how noble am i how loving am i but serve
for the sake of service because you see
the creator you see god in them and you
can't not love it and devote yourself to
it
and that to me is like the pinnacle of
achieving a state of non-dual awareness
is that
when you just love truth for the sake of
truth yes i think that's when you talk
about the direct path the accelerated
path
that's when awareness the expansion of
awareness
begins to be really accelerated because
when your heart is like absolutely
immovably devoted to truth for the sake
of truth not because it enhances me or
makes me more wise or any of that
which i wouldn't say that that's wrong
but just because truth is reality
and i want what's real and what's true
because it's true
it's part of my nature
when you become devoted to truth from
that position awareness becomes like a
like the sharpest dagger you've ever
wielded it just starts to catch anything
that's based in untruth
because because when you're in love with
someone
you don't have to
it doesn't take any effort
to be devoted to them when you're madly
in love with them
to notice whatever thoughts in you are
not
in alignment with that integrity of love
you notice them quickly and easily
but it's when you're not devoted to
something
that ego can begin to
take your attention away to other things
so being devoted to truth for the sake
of truth be doing service for the sake
of service like that's karma yoga right
it really is one of the most immediate
direct routes to liberation
[ __ ] yes
and
um
okay so then this is what in um
in
uh master your mind
that's
the core
um one of the core teachings that you'll
be communicating
yeah we just go really deep into the
three beliefs and and see the
infinite variety of ways that they show
up in our daily experience because it's
just about becoming aware right and if
we don't know what to look out for then
we won't catch it so we we give a lot of
practices and you know every day they're
doing the meditations on that module the
teaching in lack or
external fulfillment and it's just like
sharpening my
awareness of those energies so that when
they show up i just start to catch them
quicker and quicker right
yep that's and that's the metacognition
component to it right
it the master your mind is teaching
metacognition and it's it's so good it's
i love that so then that okay so that
eight-week course um is something you're
teaching at is that that's the beginning
of 2022
uh that one's just year-round like an
evergreen kind of thing it's also
everything cool yeah so anyone who signs
up for that as soon as you sign up you
get access to module one and each module
opens up one week later so that's that
one uh is kind of an anytime thing the
living the course program begins
january 1st through december 31st
okay yes
sweet
um and that's a
course in miracles the living the course
cool and that's year long so i love this
i also love aaron so much because he
distills out what he learns
into
courses so so this is another really
important thing for our for our
audiences is like if you want to
integrate one of the best ways to
integrate is to be like what did you
learn like well what like what happened
like what is metacognition like you tell
me how to handle a negative emotion now
um
and then that's great because then if if
if you turn awareness on itself and its
process um you unite more and more
intimately with the one in its nature
and you learn how to teach your other
selves in the process because now look
at what aaron has aaron has this massive
library of his content that he's put
into evergreen courses so it's also not
something that he has to keep his
attention on which is another good thing
is to for everybody to consider is like
well there's new strategies that exist
where you can package in your content uh
over a period of eight weeks so you make
videos two videos um
for each week let's say and then those
16 videos are able to people to access
any time they want as an evergreen
course and so
um it's so good and then you get to
collaborate with other people as well
like on your other projects the lava and
book club as well um along with the
living the course is that you get to
build great relationships with people
that you can co-create these courses
with so if somebody else is like waking
up with you it's a perfect opportunity
for you guys to both sit down and like
hey let's like let's design something
around what uh we've experienced and
share that with our friends and so it's
just it's a cool feedback loop of the
one teaching itself to teach learn and
teach yeah
yeah i i totally agree that one of the
best parts about doing any course or
program and there's so many good ones
out there is the community that you get
to go on the journey with
it really does so much of the work for
itself just being in community with
other people devoting themselves to
these truths and doing the work every
day with other people it's
i can't remember where this is i feel
like it's in one of the vedas but they
list the five um like five essential
components for self-realization
you know stillness of mind is one um
compassion for all beings love for all
equally is one and one of the five that
they list is uh satsang
community with the wise with others
and so whether it's you know there's
bentino's course or one of your courses
or one of my courses you get with people
who are all doing that work
and it just crystallizes and compounds
in such a way that it it just seems
exponentially um more direct than trying
to go it alone
and there's you know there's nothing
wrong with that either but um if you're
looking for right the most immediate
direct route if you don't want to waste
time
then i think get into a community of
people that are doing this work whatever
the work is
and that will be probably the best thing
you can do for your spiritual growth
yes ah so good
so good
um
it's it's so true um
because like the faster that you
surround yourself with people that you
like everybody's experienced this you
put yourself
into a community or
around other people smarter than you you
become smarter really quickly um
and so find like whatever your north
star is
and um you know if that is awakening
then find the most awakened communities
and enter yourself into them but if it's
just business for now right if it's just
like making money for now what do you
want to do you want to surround yourself
with people that are wealthy and that
like know how to and so it's the same
style of satsang applies to
all
literally everything right
whether you're an athlete what do
athletes do you know wrestlers
when they want to go to the olympics
they go to an olympic training center
and they train with the best wrestlers
on earth yes um in any sport it's like
this musicians you want to play with the
best musicians you can because they're
going to sharpen you um it's absolutely
no different with spiritual seeking
consciousness olympics of consciousness
baby like athletes of consciousness i
love it olympics of consciousness it's
so good huh yeah like i feel like that's
what we're doing like the show for sure
had a greater um interest in like
science and entrepreneurship and then it
gained a greater interest in
spirituality and non-duality um
and it's really cool because now the
people that a lot of the people that
come on the show now um
i couldn't see
are
like masters of of consciousness like
and that's really cool like to put
together an olympics of consciousness
where we're we're basically we're having
dialogue about what is like the core
like quickest way for people that feel
separation that feel lack that feel like
they're trying to like extract and get
and um
right for them yeah for them to wake up
because that's what um
that's what like this is
so good this olympics of consciousness
so in a sense it's like a north star for
us now is taking the individual awakened
people and putting them together into a
global spiritual awaken community that
then works together on you know building
out the
cleanest energy the cleanest agriculture
the cleanest
basic needs being met the most artistic
actualization happening across the
planet um and all being done
with
with without creating any
separation so kids being born don't get
the onion layers added on to them but
and so then that's how the feedback loop
speeds up for earth awakening because
there's no built up separation that then
has to like be seen through and dissolve
yeah
i think that's the answer to everything
that's happening on our planet right now
is that there's just not a real
alternative to offer humanity yet to say
hey
yes this is the old system the old model
the kind of the service to self
hierarchical model governments top-down
structures
but there's another model
which is the service to others model
where no one has any rights anyone else
doesn't have
it's all an equal exchange of energy we
don't just try to punish bad behavior
but we just incentivize good behavior
and
to really have what we call an
enlightened civilization requires
somebody needs to build it at some point
like it has to be a conscious
manifestation on our part because we're
living in an old system a dying system
that's clinging
for dear life to stay alive on our
planet and as we've we're moving into
fourth density now it's going to become
increasingly
intolerable to live under that system
as the vibration lifts and we'll find
there is an increasing hunger for
something else but people don't really
know what that looks like yet
and those of us on this path know what
that should look like and have
the inspiration the passion the
excitement to build it we just got to
start building it we can't dethrone the
old system from within it it's built to
keep recreating itself as long as
there's still greed and jealousy and
pride and selfishness
in our collective consciousness
it's going to keep manifesting again and
again right so really the way out to
heal this planet and move into a fourth
density civilization is we gotta get
together get in community
and start building it and that's
exciting
and i love the feedback loop that it has
because
when when you when we collapse the
distinction between subject and object
or between consciousness and physicalism
that then we recognize that the more um
awareness love light the density of
consciousness
that
that vibration is exactly what dictates
the physical
appearance or manifestation
which then feeds back into the way that
consciousness experiences itself
and so the it closes the loop on the
subject object duality and so you
recognize that the
by far the most important thing is the
purity of the vibration of the entity
how much it knows itself and then from
there everything in manifestation
becomes so much more pure in terms of
service to others building out
shambhalas across the planet making the
conscious shift to decentralization
technologies abundance for all all of
this type of stuff which then feeds back
into people being able to go to
shambhalas instead of being hit with the
the corporate hierarchical uh
centralized uh monopolistic oligarchical
fabric that has been uh extracting for
so long um serving in some ways of
course but also um
it's as the indigenous would say it's
not in harmony with the planet and it's
not um in a seventh generation
relationship with the planet it's not
thinking 200 years in advance it's
thinking like how can i get for my
shareholders tomorrow um
so
so i'm also happy that you have a
interest in the architectures that you
have an interest in um yeah in
transitioning the planet onto the the
next
designs um
do you
that would probably also be a good spot
to tune in with you a bit on is um
are you currently
are you currently seeing the like the
decentralization of the monetary system
and the
um
the unleashing of the
uh the suppressed energy technologies
and the permacultural um styles of of
creating abundance do you do you feel
like um those are at the core on like
the physicalism side of like meeting
basic needs and um like fractional
ownership for everybody or nobody owns
also another way to say it
you'll own nothing and like it
yeah
um
i think this is one of the things that
the
um top-down power structure system
seeks to do is to really instill this
belief in lack
in the collective consciousness that man
especially like through this pandemic
right there's this um feeling created of
like gosh
the world is so dangerous and deadly and
full of evil diseases just waiting to
leap into your body and murder you and
there's so much scarcity in the world
it's there's a supply shortage
and it's all this giant illusion right
because all that's happening is the
abundance of
the planet and of reality is just being
hidden and suppressed so effectively
that people are buying into this
illusion that we're lacking there's not
enough resources to go around
so that's one of the exciting
opportunities that building an
enlightened civilization and enlightened
community offers is that
as we know there's so many free energy
technologies that have been invented
that are available but they get hijacked
you know fbi shows up and takes it away
the next day and
these people have nowhere to go to begin
using and integrating their systems
because there's really no communities
yet crying out for that stuff or
attracting that stuff
so yeah we can get into a
self-sustaining community that we build
that's totally independent of the system
we grow our own food we have our own
doctors our own medicine our own
technology everything
and then now that we're not relying on
the old system anymore we can bring in
free energy technology in our thriving
community and start using it start
putting it to use and then people will
start to notice hey have you heard that
down in wherever they are um they're
using free energy already what yeah and
it's all crypto based what yeah and it's
all self-sustaining people will find out
that this is already happening somewhere
and that will spark that will open i
think the awareness in our collective
that there is absolutely no lack there's
just abundance and we can create we can
have a world that lives in abundance
there's plenty to go around for everyone
but in the old model
it's a system built on lack right it's a
system that's built to
disempower or suppress the individual
for the sake of the institution or the
elites
and uh we have to flip that upside down
and say how do we create a society that
empowers the individual
and and that's what's really exciting is
in a truly enlightened world everyone
will just do what they're most excited
and passionate about
because as needs arise in in societies
we see this happen in our world how does
any new technology any new product get
invented it's because some needs
surfaces and then somebody gets excited
about feeling that need a passion
ignites in them and source consciousness
manifests an answer some new product
that's super innovative or whatever that
would be how society would thrive is
that everyone would just be incentivized
to find your passion and give the value
to the to the
system that you can bring
and that way there's it's value in value
out it's um
like acim says the law of love says that
giving and receiving are one
so in true giving there's always an
equal exchange right there's never like
i have to remove or deny myself
something to give it to you that's how
the old model
um
works and thrives and it's just not true
it's just an illusion right there's
absolutely ways we can provide value
that returns back to us
and not have to live under this the
system of lack anymore
ah so good feeling into
awakened
architecting it feels so good feeling
into it and
it
it's also so good when i see the little
like four-year-olds running around and
playing is like seeing them already
playing in these enlightened
civilization architectures
um it feels so good and
like that's our star that's what
motivates me
um
i love that
um
so
how to bring
let's say
um
you
me
what we're doing um with no limit
society here or what
uh
you're doing with the different
initiatives and the different
communities that you're involved with or
like aubrey marcus or whatever all of
these different spiritual communities
i'm so interested like we talked about
the olympics of consciousness how do we
bring
the spiritual communities together
to
do
the architecting
and also to
like to reflect to each other where
we can
still come from a more pure place or
where distortions may still be hiding or
um
or yeah like or like uh how to take the
things that we've refined as pedagogy
and be able to share that that type of
thing as well how do you envision all
the islands coming together
i think they they will just come
together so naturally
when we begin
encouraging people to just get in
alignment first
like stop doing things you don't want to
do
because you're you're in a sense you're
still betraying yourself in a way when
you're doing something you don't want to
do that's not your highest excitement
that's the belief in lack right well
there's not room for me to do what i'm
passionate about
or or it's oversaturated there's not
enough
you know for me to make a way doing that
these are the only beliefs that hold us
back from really stepping into
what our destiny is in this life
and i think that we just won't
realize our potential it won't and can't
be actualized until we start saying
radically saying yes to that meaning i'm
only going to do what i'm inspired to do
i'm going to i'm going to pursue
the
passion that source has placed inside me
because i know that that passion is not
my the person's passion that is actually
the source's desire manifesting through
me and so the most aligned thing i can
do is say yes to that
and it doesn't mean that you're you're
working another job while you're
transitioning or anything like that it
just means you're prioritizing your
excitement your giftings your passions
and i think that um like i went to an
event this weekend in san diego called
the heart of freedom
and met up with all my friends were down
there and everyone is so uniquely gifted
some of them are doctors
some of them are experts in crypto and
building blockchain technology
some of them are experts in um
entertainment music content creation
and we're just sitting around hanging
out with each other just looking around
like man there's nothing we can't do
in this group right here we could start
building a self-sustaining thriving
community today
and if we need another gap needs to be
filled of uh we need someone who's good
at this
trade or technology say hey i know a guy
and they invite their friend to come in
and when people feel the love the unity
in those in these circles that we build
these communities we build it is so
contagious it is so infectious it's
irresistible to people it's what
everyone is looking for right a place of
unconditional love and acceptance where
your uniqueness can be expressed and
appreciated and there's a place for you
to fill
gaps and give value back to others i
mean everyone's doing service to others
everyone's being fulfilled expressing
their passion to me that's the essence
or the foundation we have to build the
enlightened civilization upon and again
there it is right that system
incentivizes everyone equally
yeah and there's the deep trust and
there's the deep surrender and the deep
faith
that this collective is totally going
through its shift to fourth density and
that it's
very visibly having abundance and
architectures for
prosperity for everybody um but that
it's it's rough it's not a you know it's
got its war and its death and its
calamities and disease and all these
types of things that it had to go
through you know charles eisenstein also
said that about like the planets just
going through its absolute hardest
separation possible in order for it to
like a rubber band snap right into its
greatest enlightenment possible yeah
right so cool it's it's the dark night
of the soul for mother gaia i think yeah
yeah
yeah and it feels really good
when
like seeing it on a big picture timeline
feels really good because you can become
that allness
in a sense
like being the all that is falling
asleep and remembering itself and then
it and then that you know that really
inspires you too because it makes you
more formless it makes you more um
everythingness it makes you more
nothingness and and then it
decentralizes your
consciousness even more
transpersonalizes you even more um and
it feels so much better if it makes love
so much more easy to channel when you're
like that
um it makes devotion
easier too this yes
yeah
yeah i mean supreme devotion title of
our talk today
it's like i'm just devoted to the
highest good of humanity
i think um
david hawkins uses the scale of
consciousness right and talks about how
um enlightening begins at 600 700 is
self-realization and the higher up the
scale that you move
really beginning at the 500 level of
love
your natural disposition towards life
just becomes increasingly
i can only do i the only actions i'm
interested in taking are actions that
benefit the whole
because your awareness of oneness is so
great at that level that
a ramana maharshi level sage literally
every action they take every word they
speak is for the good of others
and if there if there's nothing arising
to do or to say for the good of others
they stay silent yeah i mean that's the
that's the epitome of self-realization
is that your sense of self is completely
non-divided yes that um every action you
take is is to benefit the collective
just naturally that's that's what's
exciting and i think that the immediate
route
to get there is we got to work through
a lot of this darkness that's
manifesting
you know we've had tyranny control
enslavement on this planet since day one
of humanity this has been the modus
operandi for all of human history
and we can't move towards a truly
enlightened civilization that benefits
everyone until we
meet these energies we've been
entertaining on this planet for
millennia
and forgive them and heal them and see
them as futile right see them as
irrelevant to where we're headed and
then naturally they'll drop away
and that's what we have to do in our
individual lives right so often
if you if you're really devoted to truth
that means you lose the ability to skip
over or bypass anything because you
understand everything in creation is
happening for a reason
if there's a shadow a trauma in me an
unhealed
aspect of my consciousness i can't
skip over that i have to be devoted to
healing that as well which means i have
to let myself feel
how i feel in this moment
and that's a that's a tricky one right
because a lot of times we don't want to
feel uncomfortable
especially when we are experiencing lots
of peace
and stillness
but there's still some things within us
that we haven't maybe completely healed
yet
i find myself doing this all the time
just moving through my day and there's
just a very subtle
layer of anxiety in my mind
different tax tasks i gotta do and it
builds up so slowly during the day right
where you don't recognize it until it
gets to a point where it's intolerable
and then you're like oh man i've been
i've been ignoring this anxiety all day
and just realized it
because i'll be like i'm going to go
read i'm going to go meditate i'm going
to do something because i don't want to
just feel what i'm feeling
and inquire into it right that's the
first step to true transcendence
and so when i see what's happening in
the world i see it it works the exact
same way with the planet
there's no skipping over this we have to
see you know the the child trafficking
the the drug trafficking the wars the
genocide the tyranny the authoritarian
control we have to be able to see all of
these things and understand where they
find their root in us
i can't judge the greedy elites for
hoarding all the wealth to themselves if
i have any trace of greed in me
i'm contributing to their greed i'm
manifesting their greed if it's in me
so less and less we judge the world and
more and more we look inwards and take
responsibility
and that's not the sexy thing right
that's not the shiny non-dual concept
but it is the fastest route to freedom
if you want freedom
i love the
straight up
not
talking unless it is in service to the
whole
um
so good i love the sense of self being
so decentralized that that is
or so realized is another right agree
with it
oh realize this realization is
decentralization or decentralization is
realization that's pretty cool
decentralized ego
that's also cool right
you can look at things innovations like
crypto and how how cryptocurrency is
solving
the problem of financial corruption on
our planet which i think really is
if we had to point to one thing that
contributes the most to the forms of
corruption it has to be the way finances
are manipulated in the world right
through the banking system and all this
and fiat currencies and money printing
it's like how do we get rid of that
corruption well we can't solve it in
that system we have to just build a new
one that makes the old one obsolete
and if we look at how cryptocurrency
does that
what does it do it gives you it puts all
the power in your hands to be your own
bank you don't have to depend on anyone
outside of you with your money anymore
um we as a collective decide what these
coins and tokens are worth right the
market determines the value
and so it can't be manipulated by any
one person or institution because all of
us have to agree on it right we all have
to agree that bitcoin's worth something
because if if tomorrow we woke up and
when bitcoins useless then the value
goes to zero
it's only worth what we say it's worth
right that to me is
such a great parallel to the journey of
awakening is realizing my oneness with
everything stop dividing myself stop
compar mentalizing everything you know
it's so cool how
everything is fractal right it's all
really one thing it's the same healing
evolving process everywhere you look
yeah
we could get into blockchain and all
that too
but so good
i love that the
um one of the cool yeah one of the
coolest visuals is to see
um the one as yeah just fractaling
eternally and um
expanding and exploring and um
and actualizing that potential and
just knowing that like i am that like
and that um
as i wake up i just
serve myself waking up and
um
like it just it can't really be more
like simple
than that um
like
i love consciousness right like how can
you not love consciousness right right
and that means you love everyone
yeah
right uh
so it can be so simple and kid-like too
or like i love existence and then i love
all that exists
um
you know
i love reality so simple a child can
understand it
yeah
yes
and and then like and then the child
like joy and like freedom can come up
more and
like before all of those layers because
you could even say that like the
deconstruction project that is uh
awakening or enlightenment um
in a sense it doesn't even have to
happen if there's no construction job
that happens in the first place
like of all the layers of separation and
conditions and
kitchen and the body and all this type
of stuff
yeah unworthiness
so like that's a great north star for us
is to
uh
build the future where there's no uh
onion layers for kids that even get a
bill put on in in the first place
um
yeah yeah i i love the quote
the buddha made
after he
you know attained enlightenment one of
the things he said was when i awakened
the whole world awakened with me
all at once
and um the course touches on that when
it talks about um
the christ in you is the savior of the
world when you've when you
discover your christ nature um the whole
world is saved through you
it's the same idea
which i think is touching on seeing that
innocence that essence of the creator
and everything that it's perfectly
innocent and transparent and free and
perfect
and as you recognize that in others and
in yourself you start to realize yeah
everyone's actually already free
there's just the illusion that they're
bound
they just don't know that they're free
right
so when you see someone who's deeply
lost in delusion and ego in the dream
state
you actually see that as
enlightenment in a weird way because you
realize without the dream state there's
no awakening
without illusion there's no
enlightenment so they're actually two
sides of one coin it's this process of
source experiencing itself and that
enlightenment is inevitable in every
living being whether it's in this life
or the next life but it is going to
happen and the contrast they're building
now will set the context for their
awakening later so in a way they're
awakening now they're already awakening
even though they seem on the surface
layer to be totally unconscious
and lost in delusion
a part of you recognize recognizes them
as awakened i just find that to be
interesting and it doesn't make
conceptual sense obviously but it is it
does become a lived experience
yeah and that also
plays really importantly into seeing
people as probabilities and seeing like
always being tuned into their highest
possibility
right
yeah and like seeing them already as god
as the one um and
and uh like in a very non-attached way
that's another really important thing is
the non-attachment um because
and and actually natural radiance is
what creates um
the service the service is really
anchored in the non-attached radiance of
love um
and the graspiness or the neediness of
the other to
accept
the
[Music]
the awakening that's being communicated
or whatever this uh it's it's more about
the where it's coming from in the lack
of where um the lack felt from where it
was coming from from the entity of where
it was coming from um
yeah bro i feel so good i feel so good
about
like i love how you love david hawkins
also i feel so good about his um levels
of consciousness map of consciousness
it's just so on point yeah um
yeah and like that's another one of
those like maps or symbols that we've
sort of distilled and integrated and um
and
i think that that's one of the other
cool things is like at some point
you know in 5 or 10 or 20 years like
younger people will be looking at
the people we've studied and also
they'll be studying us
and they'll be trying to distill out
what we communicated across our books
and our courses and our videos and our
content
and
it's almost like yeah it's like a
responsibility to us because that's the
fractal like nature of course
but it's like a responsibility for us to
to
um to give them as much signal as
possible as quickly as possible so i
think that would that was another point
that i wanted to mention is um
like if if you are i know it's tailored
to each individual exactly um as it is
needed for them
but like generalities in terms of
generalities for know yourself accept
yourself become the creator and
generalities
um do you typically point to things like
metacognition um for becoming aware of
of awareness do you point to
like doing shadow work for
getting through your core lack belief
seeing through them um
for becoming the creator do you point
them to like the who am i self-inquiry
teachings of ramana harshi right so yeah
what are your generalities for the most
signal fastest
yeah
well i i just love acim obviously so
much and i think it's um
in a lot of ways it's sort of just like
a handbook to enlightenment
so i do i think i probably follow pretty
closely to a lot of acim teachings the
chief of them being forgiveness
forgiveness is just the act of becoming
non-divided
unseparated inside myself and there's
different ways you can even teach
forgiveness you don't have to use that
word
but um
non-dewarship is one of my favorite
things to teach just because of i think
the realizations that are available if
and i acknowledge that it takes some
time to sit with for for most that to
say you're not doing anything is the
most ridiculous idea the mind can
entertain
because man it's one convincing illusion
but
to begin to penetrate through the facade
of ego by by pointing people to their
direct experience i think is the most
powerful because their direct experience
will begin to show them
um these truths naturally
so to give a pointer like
what we call the person that we think we
are that we relate to as me
is actually really just these five sense
organs and i'm just sensing i'm
experiencing taste touch smell sight and
all that
and it appears because of the five of
those happening all the time it it feels
like there's a person doing it
yes yes so it's like go to your senses
and find out
through daily inquiry find out if
there's a person doing
hearing
it's being done
by an individual entity
or does it feel more accurate and honest
to just say that it's sort of just
happening
and there isn't anyone at the helm like
don't hear this
just stop hearing this right if you're
the hearer don't hear what i'm saying
you start to question those things and
it breaks down that illusion and you say
oh yeah there's actually no hearer
but hearing is happening there's no seer
but seeing is happening and you start to
disidentify from so many of those
illusions
and in my at least in my course by
teaching this in many different ways
it starts to give people some
breakthroughs in their ordinary
perceptions their dualistic perceptions
and they start to have
an experience of what it means to say
there is no doer
doing the living i'm just being lived
and that's living from flow right once
you're once you start to connect with
flow
man spiritual growth becomes so
accelerated so easy so natural so simple
because it's all being done already
right you're just sort of we get in the
way of our own awakening by thinking
that we're doing it
rather than that it's just unfolding
through grace so it's like that's what i
try to show my students a lot is that
you're not in charge of this ship of
awakening right it's just happening in
you already so it's like get out of the
way surrender to it allow awakening
rather than do awakening
so good awakening is allowed not done
it's big
so good yeah
so good yeah life is a mat is an
infinite processing system and to like
allow the processing system to to happen
um to expand um
yeah rather than the contracted sense of
self to do
um so good such a good like
um contrast there and um
and then to associate oneself like
identity wise with life with the
processing system um with the allowance
um
and then i would also like to ask that's
great for parsing for for signal and
then i'd also like to ask um
so we with no limit society with bentino
have been doing a lot of work on um on
desire and like the juxtaposition
between desire and like wanting right
right right craving is like ego
grasping and like desire is like god
desire is like the expansive force of
the universe it's like
abundance shambhala's yeah this type of
thing yeah so
tell tell us about how you feel around
like desire like the north star
creativity yeah how do you feel about
that
i love it i love your um
using that north star analogy so good
yeah like you're you're always devoted
to something yes
whether you know it or not might as well
devote yourself to the highest
yes and just to play on the the book um
that i first wrote uh last year called
high level perception the logo was a
triangle with a star at the top
nice
right that's because that's what it is
like that's the north star perception
you're always whatever's in that
position is what is the probability
space is carving itself out how it's
current right now yeah yeah right well
going back to how we were saying
let life live you let awakening happen
get out of its way
um icim uses the teaching i need do
nothing
and it says
like that that phrase i need do nothing
it says is a statement of allegiance
a truly undivided loyalty
and then it says believe it for just one
instant and you will accomplish more
than is given to a century's worth of
contemplation
that's pretty radical
yeah
but it's like do i believe that because
what matters is do i believe it right i
can have the shiny concept and i can
teach about it make
memes about it or whatever
but do i really believe it
because if i believe it it'll show up in
my devotion to life it'll show up in my
daily surrender
it'll be evidenced in the way i engage
with my life there will be this loss of
ability to resist
you know what i mean there will be a
loss of ability to criticize what's
happening
and more and more just a stepping into
it and opening a softening emerging with
what is and that's where power is that's
where
divine potential is actualized
so that's what i'm always excited about
in my own life and when you talk about
the the experience of living from
abundance to me that's that's the whole
essence of it right there
bro i feel like we are even just getting
into flow right now like together right
yeah yeah
so you can feel it when you're in it
yeah i feel so good um
dude okay so und this was so good um
when you say i i need do nothing
um and then this like the und the
non-division and the undivided loyalty
the supreme devotion really kicks in
just like you said just the like the
allowance of that um
the flooding of then the love and the
light that comes forth the service that
comes forth
but contrasting that with studying the
libraries full of concepts i love that i
love that contrast
because it's so true that you could
spend
millennia reading the corpus of this
collective
but
you would never
in that time
learn i need do nothing
and then if you really allow for that
for a bit i like how you said um there's
a loss of resistance that's perfect
there's a loss of resistance
um emerging with what is yeah
and then i love this i love the
simultaneity of
the
of the of the merging of what with with
what is the loss of resistance to what's
appearing
and also recognizing that what's
appearing is just god's will of the past
in the present
and so then you sort of
you unfreeze more and more of your will
and you recognize that right now i am
creating what i'm going to experience in
a year
so do i do i want to
uh
do i want to write a book do i want to
start a show do i want to hang out with
some friends do i want to move back to
my hometown do i move to a different
country but from right now
with your creator stylist
is god expanding itself into its potent
infinite potential so yeah
and that's a great way to
to like simultaneously recognize the
non-resistance and the creatorhood you
are an infinite creator and so to like
see the simultaneity of that no
resistance to what is because it's just
a collection of what has and also a
just like so much of like an adoration
for the paintbrush
also
um
another way you could we could look at
devotion or you know bhakti it's like
being devoted to my highest potential
you start to see that as sort of the
highest act of worship that you could
give to the creator is that the creator
has made me a fractal of itself
to express some amazing
aroma essence fragrance of what it is so
what better service what better love
what better worship could i give the
creator than to allow again that
potential to be realized
it just it's so intuitive isn't it
something in you just knows that this is
the highest form of worship it's like i
could worship christ
from a distance i could worship him on a
pedestal and that's um maybe helpful at
a certain elementary level of our
spirituality but at another level you
start realizing no no
to become christ
is the greatest act of worship to christ
right to manifest christ is the highest
form of worship or love
and so then you begin
becoming busy getting about your
father's business as christ said because
you realize it's it's the same thing
like like the course teaches god's will
and my will are one there's only god's
will you just haven't realized it's
actually your will
and when you introduce a separate will
that's what we call suffering
just don't do that right
[Laughter]
[Music]
so good
don't introduce
separate
sense of will
that equals suffering
always and all the
time so good
as byron katie says but only a hundred
percent of the time
[Laughter]
[Music]
and like and like i love i love where
where we've been going also with with
recently with
with desire and uh and like the law of
attraction um abraham hicks because
what you have is you have this god's
will that becomes roaring out of your
heart
it's god's will roaring out of your
heart in service to itself awakening in
service to having the shambhalas for the
children to come
it's so good it's and that's like
it's just there's no
there's no
oh my gosh when you reflect back like 10
years ago to how much more contracted
and serviced to self-oriented
wow what a liberation
what
a liberation what freedom um and so just
to shift the polarity to service to
others and to like moving attention like
more and more away from
serving myself and getting for myself
but to shift attention towards others
serving others i mean that in itself is
such a strong teaching like karma yoga
like you said like that's
that is such
uh you could say one of the most rapid
accelerative paths even more so than
jana than the knowledge or bhakti
bhakti is great too and so is yana but
like yeah karma yoga can really quickly
um
push you from
a service to self ego oriented state of
being to
oh yeah
yeah
you know ram dasa's guru maharaja
famously whenever people asked him how
do i become enlightened he would say
feed the poor
i was like that's my highest teaching
you know
and i see that that karma
karma yoga is really bhakti the the same
thing at the
ultimate essence of what they are it's
it's devotion to
to love and uh i talk about this
sometimes in other interviews i do that
i grew up christian i did uh i was a
worship leader i did the christian thing
for 23 years and uh
as we all know the christian religion
as it is today at least
has very distorted theology very
distorted understandings about the
divine
but what they do really well is the
bhakti
they worship god relentlessly they sing
songs of praise they they do service to
others feeding the homeless i was always
doing that stuff yeah
and
when i left christianity when i had my
awakening out of religion at 23 i went
headlong into
the more masculine oriented religions of
buddhism
taoism and to an extent hinduism
learning about the wisdom approaches the
nyana right what i wanted was wisdom at
that point because i had so many
distorted beliefs about god
and so i spent you know five to seven
years just diving into those texts and
teachings and man it served me a ton of
good it was absolutely what i was
missing
but at a certain point i became i think
a little too over balanced on the wisdom
side and i had
for almost years i had sort of forgotten
that god is love
and god can be loved and experienced as
love god had become an intellectual
pursuit
right
and i
was
going through a really intense bout of
depression
because i had all these shiny spiritual
concepts
that weren't getting my getting rid of
my depression
it's like i know
nonduality i can teach it really well
but i'm still depressed and this was
years ago when i was living in the bay
area
and i got to this point where i just
broke down one night and just started
crying out to god just complaining being
like i don't know what else to do i
devote my whole life to spiritual
seeking i [ __ ] meditate i
try to forgive people um i read i study
like what else do i need to do to get
liberation
and it was like
a ray of sunlight bursting through the
clouds or something i swear this like
voice
dawned inside of me and said
aaron didn't you forget that god is love
you forgot that i'm love you just think
i'm i'm knowledge now
yeah
i was like so good and
i did forget that and at that point
what felt like the best medicine to me
because i was just so you know
depression is like being so
self-absorbed it's it's a type of
narcissism in a way
i was so depressed with me and my sad
story that what felt like medicine was i
wanted to go
to children's hospitals and sit with
dying children love them and bring them
toys and you know do something to get
out of myself and get beyond myself
so that's what i started doing and like
you said it was the most immediate way
out of that dark night it started to
fill my heart with the love of god and
that love became the medicine i was
looking for it lifted my soul to a
higher vibration
to where now i can actually integrate
these shiny concepts i've collected
because the foundation for everything is
love if you don't have love you're
missing the picture still
wow
what a good take on fourth and fifth
density um there that's good and then
the unification in six that's so good
because
um
and i actually i really like putting it
like that way like where you have a
like a abrahamic style of service
uh and like the love there and then you
have this like
uh hindu dao buddhist style wisdom
uh and like the merging of the two i
mean it's it's
it's it can be a cool way to to view it
like you have to have the wisdom of
yourself as the one infinite creator as
capital s self with no lower case s self
but you also have to have this christ
consciousness
of love
of just infusing every single moment
with
and
and just
in that vibration like yeah and those
two together are unstoppable unshakable
um indestructible
eternal infinite i mean abundant
prosperous
uh giving there's
so so rich such a good way
such a good way to put it
that's the know yourself
love yourself and then become the
creator yes if you can't know yourself
and love yourself then you definitely
can't become the creator right
yes
so cool um
another one um
that i feel is good to to touch on you
is
that
um
when you have
a
a myriad of people that are seeking and
that are attending like you've you've
sort of um
you've
you've created new operational
efficiencies for yourself where you've
created evergreen courses things like
that
where now people can come and like take
the evergreen course and that way
you don't have to
focus time on the daily to that right
it's a recurring thing it's it's quite
nice like that
um
the the question is like
when you're having people hitting you up
on instagram and asking you a question
sending you an email asking you for a
zoom call taking one of your courses
they have a question about what they had
on the course
um
that you're also trying to design new
courses
um
do you do you have
a um
do you do you have of like a
prioritization
do you feel like it just naturally
organically sort of flows like your
attention to what's most important
continuously and like flow um do you
also have some sort of like a structural
like analysis of of um like
like oh there has been a backlog that
has picked up of
replies that i need to get to how has
that process been like for you as
somebody that's emerged more and more as
teaching
that's a that's an interesting question
no one's ever asked me that
uh as i think about it
i think it's it's mostly intuitive i
just sort of do the best i can
with what's happening and i try to give
my energy and attention to whatever
life seems to be demanding the most of
it
so i can't
over extend myself in any one direction
i found um martyrdom becomes a big part
of it right like
i gotta answer every single question
every email every dm every comment
uh it just becomes impossible because
you know you're only one person in this
relative reality so
that's why i agree with you that
creating different courses creating
content and putting many many modalities
out there that people can
whatever path is resonating with them if
they're interested in law of one or acim
or just basic non-duality teachings you
know you've got different things
available
but yeah i'm just really always trying
to be present with what's showing up
and uh what's what's demanding the most
of my attention right now and just to be
with that and it takes a lot of
self-love to get to the place in any
career any profession but certainly like
teaching
when you're like i'm just tired
like yeah i have a backlog i've got all
these people that are saying hey i'm
depressed i'm suicidal help me
but i can't give the best version of
myself when i'm burnt out
so the most loving thing to do for me
for everyone involved is to rest for now
i'll come back to this tomorrow that's
been a hard one
i think for all of us yes but it is an
aspect of the love and wisdom balance i
think
cool
so good
wow
so beautiful
um
i i wanna i wanna mention again um
what you said earlier about uh
trent the the s
that the very thought of i am incomplete
or not enough is exactly what creates
the sense of separation it creates the
sense of lack or unworthiness or needing
to get something to be whole um and if
we sort of nip that one in the butt
right off the bat
um the sense of wholeness or love that
arises from their light oh i love that
so i think that that's really critical
for all of us that are listening is that
specific thing like from this episode
that's such a good direct pointing like
right at the source right at the heart
of it um right at like the direct path
of it that was so good aaron so good
yeah it's a teaching that endlessly
um teaches me more every single day
you just you just become more aware of
the ways you're still perceiving lack
and it's like i don't i don't know if
that ever ends at a certain point it's
like it's almost an endless deepening
you can have because abundance is
infinite
so it almost makes me wonder if the
realization of abundance will just keep
happening
which i have no problem with because
it's it's an exciting and blissful
journey to become more aware more aware
more aware of what's available
and begin actualizing it
yes and like unite
more and more intimately and truthfully
and honestly with what was
um
what gave rise to you you like yeah you
like you become in source
you remembering source like that deepens
deepens deepens and the way you express
yourself purifies and purifies and
purifies and that that's the lesson that
we go on this adventure into and then
there's that great video that aubrey and
charles recently published on um
on aubrey's channel about how it's like
we decided aaron we decided
to come on behalf of this one infinite
creator to come to this collective and
to go through this soul journey
and to
serve this collective in its process and
just like that insight also is so
can be so powerful too is that
i purposely created for myself this
divine experience
and the school the school the school the
school it's it can take you
so far to see it as
as a school
um yeah like ramada says who was it
that said that to ramdas
um
you're already in the university now
might as well start taking the
curriculum
yeah
[ __ ] you're already in the
university baby that's right this is the
university man we're enrolled already
yes
yes
and
and um yeah ben also said something
recently interesting too is like you're
already in the like the war zone like
this is it like so do the sto do the
service to others there's nothing else
you can do no amount of extracting
uh any try any kind of external thing
for happiness will work it won't
so you may as well go so hard towards
service to others now and for the rest
of your life you're already in the war
zone you're you're um you're already in
the university
yeah it's so good man
when you say that it um sparks a
metaphor i use sometimes
uh about
the journey of service to others and how
it
allows us to leave this density and move
to a fourth density consciousness
if you imagine like if you fell asleep
every night and you kept having the same
nightmare of being in a war zone
and there's just land mines blowing up
body parts flying people dying blood
everywhere just absolute hell and chaos
and you have this nightmare every night
and so you're in the nightmare and
you're terrified so you're you're
shooting your gun and trying to kill as
many people as possible out of fear out
of the belief that you're separate
and but nevertheless every night you
keep having that same dream
and then at a certain point it occurs to
you maybe if i change my relationship to
the dream it'll stop happening so the
next night you get in the dream and you
start you put the weapon down and you
start running around rendering medical
aid right to people and dragging them to
safety and rescuing as many people as
you can
and then all of a sudden the dream
changes into a beautiful dream and then
it leaves your experience and you stop
having that nightmare
like it's a perfect analogy for what
third density is
we're here to experience polarity
light and dark and make whatever choice
our soul authentically wants
light or dark
but make no mistake you will not leave
this realm until you choose light or
dark and so when you
start living from service to others that
is your declaration to the universe
right this is the path i'm choosing have
committed to this path this is my way
out of this density
and at a very
um
the universe doesn't require too much of
us it's like just show me your hearts
devoted to love and service and then
you've you've passed that grade of
school right you can go to the next
grade
we just don't realize the game we're
playing and that becomes the real
challenge of third density
such a good analogy
and such a good dream metaphor so
perfect
yeah so
you're in the war zone
you're in the war zone stop shooting and
killing people you know be a medic
and um
and then shambhala manifests and then
it's the end of the dream and then
before you know it you're on to another
more difficult more complicated more
adventurous
dream where you'll also forget and start
with shooting people um it's so good
so good bro
what a good way to rap i'm i'm like so
in love with this this is really strong
like i feel a really cool brotherhood
emerging here
and likewise brother
it's so good
it's so good it's it's like
like bro like i just have a whole page
full of good wow
from plus student man yeah it's so good
bro you're like
there's just so many good ones and um
and like the the tennis was really good
and um
and i think it's just the beginning of
being able to like
have these great wisdoms and loves loves
and wisdoms uh arrive
together
and um and perhaps even the beginning of
some more conversations maybe some
co-creations on some course stuff too um
there's so much good
to to blossom from here some
co-creations on shambhalas on the on the
planet's next architectures
so
most definitely so pumped bro
i appreciate you having me on man i've
loved it it's been a blast
so good to hear yeah there's many more i
want to share let's see if i can get
uh some of the
content up yes okay so let's start off
uh with
this is uh yeah this is aaron's
instagram you can go and give him a
follow all these links are in the bio
below um by the way you also have um
this is his link tree link you can find
the living the course which is
here
this is the year long
for a course in miracles
with him and mark anthony lord and then
you can find also here the master your
mind
and that's
here the master class
this is such a cool feature man
it's so nice i love it and then yeah
restream baby love this and like and
like uh hopefully other people can see
like how easy it is just hit this up
show available time slots book your free
discovery call this is a great way um to
just shatter through um any egoic uh
layers increase metacognition
um
bring forth happiness lasting happiness
becoming the creator um so this one's
great it's only eight weeks
the love one book club also
um
so this is aaron and krista williams
so this is another one that you guys can
check this is so good for law of one so
good guys um
so this link's in the bio and then also
the conscious vitality is also in the
bio um
yeah
so
that's some of the some of the core
offerings that you guys can check out um
and definitely uh just even the simple
subscription also to his youtube
channels another great place um to and
like like if this video brought you
value also like it and share it with
people this is another great way to
share what aaron represents with people
sharing the video itself liking it
subscribing to the channel commenting
below with what you know what was said
that really resonated with you um drop
it in the comments and let us know and
we would love to we would love to hear
from you
and
yeah that's that's all any uh any
closing closing thoughts
oh man it's just been such an enjoyable
conversation i love how easy it is to
drop into flow with you
um
i do so many podcasts and uh you know
everyone has their own unique style and
that's fine but a lot of times podcasts
are the questions are scripted
and so there's
there's always like a break like we go
from one topic and then let's talk about
acim then tell me about law of one and
we just jump around it feels kind of
disconnected
but i love when i can talk with someone
who we let
the conversation itself dictate what
happens and i think we had a really
delicious flow in this conversation so i
appreciate you and the way you
facilitate man
thanks so much it was it was so nice
that that summarizes it really well for
me too um
and it's organic like that with uh with
when the vibration is like harmonized
together like that yeah um because then
we hit all of the topics that were
divinely meant to arise in the convo and
and so many more so many more to come um
so thank you everyone for tuning in love
you so much thanks aaron again for
coming love you guys
so much love so much love um i'll end
i'll end the stream and then you and i
will stay in the studio for just a
minute okay cool
bye everyone
you